when there's certainly a shorthand we
have from you know having this been the
third film we've shot together now and
you don't spend a chunk of your shooting
time getting to know one another
you know we able to pick up where we
left off and have developed a great
friendship along the way and um I don't
like from the beginning we were lucky we
just had a chemistry in the same kind of
enthusiasm and you know this the
relationship I look forward to you know
it's really delving into every time is
being able to ask the questions that
Thor and Loki haven't really had the
acute focus to do so yet and this
instance was that you know that was a
great opportunity we had I Love You Man
I love it's absolutely true I um it's um
you know from from the beginning of
Kenneth Branagh so all the way through
Joss Whedon's Avengers and into into
Allen's dark world through them it's it
has been an amazing adventure for both
of us and and the two characters define
each other and need each other and all
antics is about um what happens in the
space between people and and and the
more you trust each other the deeper you
can go and when I'm on set with Chris
whatever he serves I'll return and he
will return them back and and and that
is the joy of it for me another theme in
this is that's it sibling rivalry know
you've got two brothers and I just
wondered whether you drew a relationship
with them to inform your interactions
with Loki she also is there phone access
do you find that it's a lot of
competition between the hands weapons ah
neither of them have attempted to take
over the universe just yet but I think
I'll have the same reaction if I did
what we're competitive the siblings are
and kind of everything from sport and
backyard cricket football surfing to
who's controlling them I control
watching TV this industry not so much
you know I think we certainly all three
of us understand the sort of frailty and
inconsistency of you know had the work
and
you know we'd help each other with
auditions and always have and whatever
scripts are working on and you know
you're not direct competition anyway and
and and it's more of a kind of team
effort with this this than than anything
else one of the scenes where they're you
know in the spaceship sort of exiting as
God that Tom and I were pretty insistent
on saying now this has got to feel like
you know when you're in the back seat
with your siblings and you know but we
couldn't get a hundred metres down the
road before the three of us would be
like get off me don't touch me you know
and and that kind of you know certainly
played into that scene and a lot of the
stuff you understand what it's like to
have that kind of love/hate sort of
thing and you do anything for them but
the same time the simplest things can
annoy you and and yeah I did certainly
you know try and draw from whatever
experiences I've been through or can
empathize with frustration towards one
sibling I have two sisters and them so
it's it's slightly differently different
they've long hair but yeah I mean I
suppose the thing about siblings is they
they know you they know you they know
you better than anyone and there's that
that thing of always being bound
together by your histories is is
something there's something very honest
about the interaction that you can't lie
in front of your your your siblings and
I love in in this film I love that
tongue Thor is able to to to demand from
Loki but he played his hand
Loki someone who's constantly in control
he'll never show you how he really feels
and the only person who gets close to it
is four and that seems very true of
sibling relationships and I absolutely
second the spaceship scene I've actually
been on a road trip with Chris and Liam
and sir
you're the worst choice
yeah it's quicker no it's not if you
spend time with Luke Jesus is like you
just seem like knocks both the heads
together and said shut up boys
he's the older brother runs the show yes
my question first of all to naturally
obviously in the first film Jane was
very much a spectator whereas this time
she's right in the middle force world I
wonder if that was part of what excited
you about the prospect of coming back I
guess with Christmas home how nice was
it for you to this time I have a very
beautiful third wheel - you're gonna
that's very nice thank you
yeah it was it was exciting to get to
come back and work with everyone I mean
people who we're joining this time and
also because Jane gets to go to Asgard
this time I was looking at to get to
work more with Tom and testings with
Renee and Anthony - were amazing and I
just got to admire from afar and then
also just continue the fun rapport with
with Kat and Stella and Chris and
there's definitely a lot of laughing
maybe too much less interesting DVD
extras on this yeah
but yes it was brilliant to have Natalie
there and to break up some of the the
godly testosterone another thing with
beautiful Jane yeah I I loved working
with Natalie in in the first film
Loki's aware of Jane Foster's presence
and refers to her but it was so fun to
see what happens when the two share the
same space violence as you see of course
you recently called Britain the new
Hollywood's proposed bill and I just
want to ask you to or me what's it like
comparison filming in Hollywood's how
different is it filming in UK ah the
interesting thing about Hollywood is I
mean I'm not a lot of stuff gets shot
there anymore obviously once upon time
it did but it's predominantly kind of
sets and Studios the nice thing about
here is
incredible studios but there's brilliant
locations to take advantage of and I
love the aesthetic this film has because
you know not only as God but we get to
see London and and you know most of
these films are set with New York or
American city is the backdrop and I love
that difference in yet do love shooting
here yeah I would I don't
Kress and that is it's hard to compare
because we don't really shoot and so I
love working here though and I'm envious
of British actors and British crews cuz
American and Australian actors - we end
up like gypsies you know you know moving
a movie you're moving cities all the
time and you can really have such a
fulfilling wonderful rich career doing
between the theatre the TV here and the
and the film all in London it's pretty
pretty cool to get to live in warming
scene please yeah I just wanna bring
Kevin on actually because Marvel have
used London a lot are going to use
London on future what's it about London
that's that that's so great for your
studio well it's no secret that there's
a that there's a very good tax incentive
which lures the studio's here I don't
want to pretend that's not the case but
but what keeps us here what keeps us
coming back are the amazing crews which
is unbelievable we're starting our
fourth film next year at Shepperton and
it's been an amazing experience all for
them if call me calls anything to go by
and people really love Loki what do you
think it is about Loki that people seem
to really love kind of more over thorne
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa several more
years of Brotherly therapy tomorrow yeah
you know Dante what I love about look we
talked about this all morning it's
really hard to UM go as well but I I
don't know that it was ever the plan to
have Loki in this many filmed but purely
to do with everything that Tom brought
to the table in the first one and how
incredible he was and the the mixture of
of strength and villainous and mischief
and and vulnerability which is such an
access point you can immediately kind of
empathize with this misunderstood guy is
why he was kept you know if my correct
Kevin why he kept bringing him back into
every film like I don't know that was of
the plan but I mean my hat goes off to
Talman and I think he's done such an
incredible job in every film and
hopefully we can keep sneaking him in
more forcefully I Love You Man
I wanted to say in response to the
second part I think Loki is defined by
Thor he's defined in opposition to him
that they are yin and yang they are the
sort of the Sun in the moon that the
whole point of them is that they are in
opposition and the whole sort of firm I
don't know that the popularity of the
character has been such an amazing
surprise I had never expected it in my
wildest dreams and I don't know I found
him a fascinating prospect because he's
a mixture of of playfulness and Tom and
mischief that's his moniker he's the god
of mischief so there's a playfulness to
him but he's such a broken but broken
character he's grief-stricken and bitter
and jealous and angry and lonely and
proud and so the cocktail of all of his
kind of psychological damage and
and his playfulness as an actor is just
a really interesting thing to inhabit
and by the way you are the only thought
now that God then a guy gotta go know
someone's going those free phones oh I'm
so grateful to hear that that's what's
coming back from the audience's they
start to see the film for the first time
I think I went into it I thought my
first task was to darken the world and
deepen it and dirty it up a little bit I
searched all like that was my mandate
going in and then as we started the
process I realized whoops
if we're gonna darken it if we're gonna
deepen it if we're going to possibly
kill off some characters that we love we
better make darn sure that it's balanced
on the other side because you know the
key to the Marvel Universe in the marble
language that I was being assaulted by
while I was making this movie because
Avengers came out Paul we were starting
in Iron Man 3 P my boy were finishing it
was you are screwed if you don't also
keep it funny and light on its feet at
the same time so it's it's called the
dark world and there's certainly dark
currents in it but yeah the humor was
critical and I can't say enough great
things about Stalin he's he was the
first thing we shocked I think we
started with him and I'm stunning and
running around with a thong he's
probably one of the few men I know who
walks into it didn't even bat an eye
from second it's hilarious and always
truth always performance is great and a
speaking of a comedy I mean for bringing
a cat in and this one I'm delighted to
see that Darcy still can pronounce me on
there which is which is cry it's a lot
of improvisational on the set of the
movie like this yeah there was a little
bit of improv in my first day back and
I'm I'm on the show in the States which
allows is no improv whatsoever and so
when you guys told me I could do that I
didn't know do I was very jet lag so I
think banana balls came out of B I was
very happy to be back
you guys gave Darcy some awesome things
to say seen a lot of great develop for
from the first film to tell engines now
this how do you develop as an
now listen also for Alan and are
surprised to find that this is actually
on the more shorter films shorter Marvel
films so what was the other two process
like and how much specifically expect to
see deleted scene ones or as Chris goes
for us yeah
the yeah I mean every film I look back
and go okay now now I get it and I start
the next one go don't a clue what I'm
doing um you know it's nice to be able
to approach your character again and for
the third time the target in a different
way with a different director and have
whole new you know bag of ideas and
influences and ways to approach it
yeah and I you know I think I grew up as
a person as well as you do through time
strides enough and as did the and so for
that echoes into whatever you're doing
and your work and um you know it was
nice to have a more mature Thor who was
sort of less petrol at an arrogant and
teenager you know as the first one it
was at times but that transition into
him understanding the the darker side of
the throne and that responsibility and
the sacrifices I was wonder play with
yeah it was there's that there's a so
many obligations to a movie like this as
I said before you know it has to be dark
and emotionally engaging it also has to
be funny and constantly earn it's it's
sort of entertainment value and part of
that process is condensing and
tightening and making it you know roll
along as quickly as it can so that it is
fun mission and you know rise it can be
so naturally something's fall out that
you wish didn't fall out some things
dear to my heart that I love Chris
Michaels and I were talking about some
things that we really savored that that
had to fall away uh I'd be really
grateful if some of those appear on a
DVD right it's I'm not I think they will
I think there's about maybe ten twelve
minutes of footage only I blue right
that's great that's fantastic there was
there was some rumor going around it's
my first encounter with doing work
while the internet watches a little bit
of that in Game of Thrones but nothing
prepared me for this and there was a
rumor about a running time argument at
one point and it was funny because I
don't think anybody that I knew my
editors you mean we even know how long
movie was there was never a running time
issue was always you know how can we
make it better funnier more effective
having Al and harder so in that process
some of my children had to get murdered
and put on the floor I'm sure after we
met metaphor Kevin let them go home so I
came in for the t-shirt I do come in
peace what he's got a Superman t-shirt
maybe DC Marvel make friends um a
fantastic film guys genuine fan of all
your works not to be a bill sucky um the
film is fantastic my question is in
terms of the tone the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is matching the comics is
getting more fantastic more out there I
wonder if the humor was a part a way of
trying to ground some of that to make it
palatable and in the other sense as the
actors the cast as the world is getting
more fantastical things being a more
strange how would you find to hook
yourself as actors into grounding your
performances and trying to stay true to
your characters humor is definitely the
key yeah we've got spaceships in this
movie in other planets in this movie and
we have found that humor is an amazing
way to get the audience to sort of just
embrace and accept all of those worlds
and all that craziness and all these
costumes it's worked well for us going
back to the first Iron Man film and in
terms of grounding your performances I
start with that Christopher and work our
way down please round it no I ground you
do my ground won an award Dark Elves
existed before time again how I ground
my performance out
they'll tell you they're to suffer
well I it's interesting talking about
the humour of them I saw it last week
and was really surprised at the amount
of humor because I'm such a miserable
bastard I was completely excluded from
any of the job I was my character was
completely grounded in vengeance he was
like a maniac for revenge the idea I
think with Alan and Kevin was to to
suggest that the the Dark Elves were as
ancient a race as the Asgardians and had
a history which is why we gave them a
language and had a culture but most of
all they had a grudge which they had
slept on for millions of years what's
interesting about the film is it does
have a variety of tones and myself and a
Diwali who fortune is not here played
Algrim and curse our job was to bring
the threat and the Menace and the
jeopardy so we we grounded in bitters
well you you said earlier that you had
to get up it's 3:00 a.m. to put your
costume on and you were so bitter and
angry about time that was over there
yeah my makeup core was about three
o'clock I was in the chair about four
o'clock ten o'clock a at the set so I
was not a happy elf and Natalie yeah the
humor I think also the the fact that the
characters are going through even though
they're travelling between realms are
going through things that we can all
relate to you know for myself playing a
woman who the guy didn't call back and
disappear there's a long-distance thing
going on when it works as she meets the
parents you know those are all things
that obviously most women can relate to
most and of course I'm an immortal among
the gods and villains near me so so I
guess that's naturally more grounded but
a lot of the issues they had is dealing
with were working men I mean even the
brothers I feel like that's so relatable
as human yeah I remember Hopkins said
something to me the first day on set on
for one
we walked in and our outfits and here's
the eye patch and the whole thing and
and the sets he looked at me said no
acting required here and I think always
remember that and think like yeah don't
compete with it you know like keep it
simple and and it already sells a lot of
the work for it um yeah I can't add much
to what everyone else has already said I
suppose some the thing that I always
think is grounding about these numbers
it is it's the family relationships for
me and we're traveling through space and
time we're dealing with gods and
monsters and but the heart of the film
from my perspective is a family a father
two sons two brothers a mother and the
fractious intimate interaction they are
my god um well I think Darcy's may be
the most grounded person and even if
she's kind of Spacey in her brain she's
not in space um and I mean I think
Darcy's love for Jane and my love her
that is pretty you know easy way for me
to stay grounded in the whole thing yeah
and I get to be the outsider to all the
craziness and comments on and I think
the audience would Marvel seems to have
a very very good strategy for a universe
not just on the big screen obviously TV
as well how coordinated is that and how
far ahead are you looking at others talk
about more TV series actor shield more
phases in the cinema how is it worn
effectively so what package you're
looking at both work as it will for the
most part it is we're a very tight-knit
group at the studio so all the movies
are very very coordinating we have them
announced through the end of 2015 but
our planning as far out as as 2017 and
and sometime next year will announce
what those with those films are for 16
and 17 the TV division is up and running
now and agents of shield obviously was
their first series I know they love to
bring more things to the to the TV
screen I'm not sure exactly what
or win that will be and in terms of
shield yes they sort of queue off of
what's happening in the movies and
occasionally check in with us and go
would it be okay if we play with this
the last bet so it is quite coordinated
but it's again such a small group it
doesn't feel over like an overwhelming
task it's just a heck a lot of fun as
question for Natalie I believe your mum
keeps a scrapbook of photos that she
allows out on set as such eventualities
and all these shots in the flats II know
you through the ages do you wish that
scrapper will go away someone who can
look at themselves on DVD h10 are you
sort of not worried about your Oh image
um yeah I guess I guess the funny thing
is that it is I think the same set of
photos that she always lends out for
every movie airgun for the past 20 years
there's a lot of characters that
shouldn't have the same experiences and
family photos could do okay but they're
you know more background people aren't
really focused via all sorts of
different people have been like
photoshopped into them is a major stand
of like me Tobey Maguire from when I'm
young it took me but not real of course
Chris did actually touch on this a
little bit earlier but I'm interested
because what you know we people say
conflict is is Jar america--the is the
antagonist here but we keep talking
still about the brothers and the
romantic diner was really did I Manta
chimera with dynamic with Malekith or
what what it mean what's what's the
point of that storyline
Eddie well thing what is the point of my
story I mean the best possible were
settled as I said to my agent
listen to Kevin point of my story line
is for me to get paid final point of my
story line I'm repeating myself slightly
it's vengeance he is a maniac for
vengeance there were some scenes which
for understandable reasons didn't make
the final Court which explained a bit of
a backstory between me my ancestors and
Baal who is old UNS father but basically
the Dark Elves before the big ban before
the big ban centuries and centuries ago
were humiliated in defeat and ground
into the dirt by Odin and Malachy has
slept on that and the theme of that the
theme of that element is his vengeance
really as we know as somebody wants
somebody said you know let he who seeks
vengeance be careful to dig two graves
because it's a pointless exercise that
that's it my job was to bring a dark
element that the dark world the Dark
Elves are seeking to turn light into
darkness it's really that simple
and that classic if you like and we
needed that in a movie where our our
villain from from Avengers we wanted to
play in a slightly more ambiguous way in
order to do that we needed somebody who
could drive the entire storyline and
give for a reason to to have something
to fight against and we're all jumping
on this one I mean Malekith is a purist
he's a fundamentalist he's a zealot
one of the major themes in the movie for
me is something that most of our
characters have to confront in one way
or another and it was a quest it was a
theme that was expressed very clearly by
Malekith in the scene that you will find
on your blu-ray where he's confronting
Odin and he's he says you have to ask
yourself as I once did what are you
willing to sacrifice for what you
believe and every character goes to a
turning point like that in the movie
and Malekith is the kind of guy who
would sacrifice anything for principle
yeah and we've seen him do it and for
was the difficult version of that and
decides to go a different way
Malekith is the main enemy in this so
Loki
he's although he's seen as the enemy
he's not the main antagonist Homer I'm
deep down do you think Loki is really
evil or is it just the jealous for start
on the outside it's it's in as a
question that I've asked myself three
times it's um you know I think yeah
every villain is a hero in his own mind
and people make choices and and they
always justify those choices no matter
how misguided their motivation and and
the great privilege and thrill for me to
play this character across three films
is is is that he didn't start out that
way and and the storyline the narrative
that was afforded to me in the very
first film this idea of a young prince
who was brought up believing in his son
his right to a throne his inheritance of
his aunt is Asgard inheritance that this
whole story was a lie that he was
adopted and and left to die on frozen
rock and that that essentially is is
what breaks his heart and and all of
this is villainy all of his son his bad
guy no credentials come from something
deeply vulnerable and that's a gift
because it means across across across
Avengers across the dark world that I
can play a dynamic with Chris and with
Anthony Hopkins in Rio Rousseau witches
towards extent is he redeemable can he
be pulled back towards the light and
it's a very very fun fault line to dance
on
you